here's a little uh video compilation
what's going on over at cnn and we've
got treasury secretary janet yellen this
woman has just screwed up everything but
with that democrat privilege you never
get fired and you never have to resign
but it wasn't just the president who got
it wrong a year or so ago i want to play
for you what you said about inflation
last year listen to this
is there a risk of inflation um i i
think there's a small risk and i think
it's manageable i don't anticipate that
inflation is going to be a problem but
it is something that we're watching very
carefully
was it a mistake madam secretary to
downplay this inflation risk did that
contribute to the problems we're all
seeing right now
well um look i i think i was wrong then
about um the path that inflation um
would take as i mentioned there have
been unanticipated
and large shocks to the economy that
have boosted
energy and food prices and
supply bottlenecks that have affected
our economy badly
that i didn't at the time didn't fully
understand the white house concede that
the fed calling inflation transitory was
a mistake
i think the white house concedes that
them also calling it transitory was a
mistake because you saw it's not just
president biden his top economic
advisers also treasury secretary janet
yellen who earlier tonight told wolf
blitzer
that she was wrong to call it transitory
when she said that inflation had posed
only a small risk that was something
that you heard not just from experts
outside the administration but
repeatedly from officials here at the
white house
i hate to tell anyone to be on twitter
you guys all know my feelings about
twitter but when the white house was
coming out with that that inflation is
transitory i mean it's just going to be
this little thing for now and then it's
going to go away
every sensible person on twitter was
saying this is complete nonsense and
we're going to find out that it's
complete nonsense in a month or two but
notice biden we showed you the cold open
talking about inflation saying it's not
going to happen or it'll be temporary or
transitory or whatever or yelling
transitory inflation nobody gets fired
nobody gets blamed
think about your own life for a moment
so i run a business here right i have a
production company that runs this show i
have a business manager who handles most
of our finances and i've got a producer
over there sitting there who handles the
production of the show they're
responsible for making sure that
everything is working properly and that
the budgets make sense and we can do the
things that we want to do and we can
produce the content we want to produce
etc etc if i found out that they were
spending far more money than we had or
that they were cooking the books or they
forgot to carry the one that's a big one
uh i would probably fire somebody
michael i'm looking at you you could be
in a lot of trouble um
so that is the point nobody gets fired
but i think in their world they're
writing it off they just don't know what
a write-off is but they're the ones who
are writing it off there's little
seinfeld for you um
you get the point they can they all just
fail up and they don't actually produce
anything but what's interesting is
there's been a little shift in the
mainstream media they're starting to ask
the right questions right so i try to
give credit where credit is due wolf is
kind of addressing the right question
with janet yellen and here's cnn
kind of admitting that uh maybe this has
a little something to do with biden and
his policies road trips are going to be
way more expensive this summer we now
have nine states where the average is
four dollars and ninety cents a gallon
or higher the latest being arizona
illinois and new york california now
stands at 615 a gallon as pete mentioned
the national average 462 a gallon that's
up 44 cents from a month ago the problem
is that supply just cannot keep up with
really strong demand as people travel
more
the problem is that supply can't keep up
with demand well it was keeping up with
demand until joe biden became president
and we do know this has nothing to do
with ukraine because in the year that
biden was president before ukraine and
russia gas still went up a dollar a
gallon we've covered that many times but
they're at least addressing there are
some problems right now and things are
expensive and people are gonna have to
spend more on their road trips and
everything else here's abc's jonathan
carl talking about inflation and he
doesn't want to admit it but he sort of
has to
if you look at the numbers uh
inflation
really started to rise almost exactly
when when when biden came in the white
house now obviously that argues my point
doesn't it but but but but look at the
look at this chart on gas prices uh just
since february if you look at the i mean
it's it is a
it is a shocking increase that
you know doesn't correspond you gotta
love it like they're just such activists
that even as he's saying about something
you would find
like they're just so awful but they they
cannot hide the truth when it's so
obviously right in front of you right
that's the thing